I know you have so many projects coming  up Mary Poppins your homes with Emily  Blunt holy Blunt can you imagine a more  practically perfect Mary Poppins than  Emily Blunt we will start shooting at  the beginning of next year does that  mean the end of lin-manuel Miranda as  Alexander Hamilton is in fact coming up  let me say something you guys are gonna  be so sick of me in this partner because  I plan to out Topol topal out Ted Neely  Ted Neely I've written apart I can't age  out of so use it if I take a break  always come back yeah  so this is not the end of anything I'm  not I'm you know I don't know when i'm  leaving it but I you know I think that  I'm gonna be able I've built a house I  can come back to any time I want so I'm  really excited about that